les ministres européens de l'énergie
vont se réunir d'urgence lundi pour
évaluer tous les scénarios et en
attendant la présidente de la commission
européenne a voulu se montrer rassurante
hier elle a promis une réponse
européenne coordonnée a assuré que
l'union européenne était préparé mais on
sait que le défi est énorme pour les
européens puisque leur consommation
totale de gaz russe s'élève à 155
milliards de mètres cubes par an et que
l'ambition est bien c'est de réduire
cette dépendance de deux tiers d'ici la
fin de l'année alors comment s'y prendre
concrètement ursula von der leyen a
souligné hier à l'importance de se
tourner vers d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement en gaz est elle à
rappeler le récent accord énergétique
avec les états unis qui s'engage à
livrer du gnl du gaz naturel liquéfié
aux européens alors ce gaz ainsi l'un
des piliers centraux de la stratégie
européenne pour moins dépendre du gaz
russe mais pour y arriver les européens
vont devoir se doter de plus
d'infrastructures et notamment de
terminaux méthaniers pour regazéifié ce
gnl après un transport par bateau alors
les autres solutions avancées évidemment
ce sont les énergies renouvelables et
puis aussi tout simplement le fait de
moins consommer en tout cas le sujet
sera évidemment à l'ordre du jour du
prochain sommet européen ici à bruxelles
fin mai